once the pony is going to be taken
rook f5 so probably this was something
he was aiming for oh something's
happened sorry
we just got a result from probably too
long probably just agreed to draw okay
yeah i mean it was no no question for me
that
it's going to be a draw already okay
okay so we'll i'm not sure tori believed
that he can't win a game against magnus
yeah you know even though he had this
opportunity playing rook f2
i'm not sure in his mindset he thought
that it's an option it's a real result
possibility i think he was just so
focused on that you know doubling the
rooks on the second row he just didn't
consider anything else and uh
yeah maybe
maybe you're right judith i kind of
i don't feel qualified to
say
to say that but to say you know
okay well magnus is very unhappy it's
completely understandable but i came
back and just got away with
so you know he saved a terrible position
i mean it was totally awful awful yeah
i mean it was so bad to look at it yeah
it just looked horrible but let's let's
go and uh let's go what happens because
probably within 20 minutes we're going
to have the play-off of that right
and
so what what is happening right here and
we have another drawer okay so shall we
do a quick